le aziende che vanno bene assumono
giovani ma soprattutto alle aziende che
assumono giovani vanno bene questa mia
convinzione è venuta dopo un percorso di
qualche anno che è nata durante una
festa di bambini una festa dei bambini
di compleanno chiede i figli
probabilmente sa di che feste parlano
quelle feste dei bambini dopo tre
secondi sono tutti sudati e che magari
dove non conosciamo tutti i genitori che
ci sono ma ci si va lo stesso perché
l'argomento e l'atmosfera è di festa e
allegra parlando con una coppia loro mi
dicevano che non avrebbero fatto il
secondo figlio perché non avevano
certezze per il futuro in quanto avevano
lavori precari e questo senso di
angoscia di paura strideva molto con
l'atmosfera gioiosa del luogo e allora
io mi sono detto sa cosa posso fare
prova a pensare al problema e e da bravo
ingegnere ho iniziato a pensare a
dimensionare il problema ok iniziamo a
dimensionare di che problema stiamo
parlando e mi sono chiesto ma quanti
sono i giorni disoccupati in italia
qualcuno di voi lo sa quanti sono
proviamo a dare un aiutino come si fa
nel nel quiz e milionario diciamo che i
giovani disoccupati in italia sono tanti
quanti una la popolazione di uno stato
dal centro europa dove ci sono tanti bei
castelli è quella di uno stato
mediterraneo dove ci sono quelle
splendide spiagge ancora niente
ebbene i disoccupati in italia sono
tanti quanto la popolazione del
lussemburgo e di cipro messe assieme
è un po come se dovessimo trovare lavoro
a tutti i lussemburghesi e tutti i
ciprioti che venissero in italia insomma
per farla breve disoccupato in italia
fonte istat sotto dai 15 ai 34 anni sono
un milione 714 mila
ed ecco ben insomma il problema
l'abbiamo ridimensionato adesso da
risolvere è un po più difficile
allora mi sono chiesto ma quante sono le
aziende in italia no ci sono forse le
aziende che non non solo numero
sufficiente per poterli accogliere in
realtà la genialità e sono tantissime
sono oltre 4milioni 400mila
allora dico ma ci sono così tante
aziende ma ci sono anche così tanti
giovani disoccupati
come mai intanto prova a far la prova
proviamo assumere dei giovani no
fregandocene anche dell'articolo 18
proviamo ha visto nel nostro piccolo noi
siamo una realtà di 50 persone abbiamo
messo dentro otto persone sotto i 30
anni e in tre anni risultato il
risultato è stato di crescere il
fatturato di quasi il 30 per cento ma
bene due li si fanno una prova di qua
sono stato fortunato
in realtà ci sono un sacco di belle
aziende che continuano assumere giovani
hanno programmi di assunzione dei
giovani per molti anni decine di
migliaia
allora ancora qui non capivo le aziende
che vanno bene assumono giovani ci sono
un sacco di aziende cosa c'è che non va
forse non ci sono abbastanza aziende
grande sufficienza per assumere tante
persone
in realtà le aziende che hanno più di 5
addetti in italia sono 420 7.196 qui
dentro ovviamente c'è una delle piccole
aziende molto grandi però sono 420 7.196
allora
un milione e 700 mila giovani
disoccupati 427 mila aziende sopra i
cinque dipendenti ben basterebbe che
ognuno di queste aziende per tre anni
assumesse una persona una una lo ripeto
perché è facile basterebbe che ognuna di
queste aziende per i prossimi tre anni
assumesse una persona e avremmo creato
un milione 300 mila posti di lavoro di
più che porterebbero disoccupazione
giovanile in italia a livelli
assolutamente fisiologici è che a
michele tu la fai semplice no lì dentro
ci sono le aziende piccole aziende
grande certo certo ma siamo stati capaci
di calcolare il livello di emissioni di
co2 e fare in modo che i paesi li
potessero come dire negoziare fare il
trading non siamo capaci di creare un
sistema di compensazione dove le aziende
dovessero comunque prendersi in carico
di questi giovani
beh sì la fai semplice e se le persone
non vanno bene si potrebbe pensare che
lo stato si impegni a formare questi
giovani di modo che una volta arrivati
in azienda avessero le caratteristiche
che servono a me e le parti sociali
magari poter favorire questo tipo di
meccanismo credo che però la cosa che
bisognerebbe fare davvero sia quella di
cambiare mentalità avere coraggio
avere tanto coraggio più coraggio e
magari anche per valutare un azienda non
solo per il fatturato per l'utile che
sono proprio quei due numeri che sono i
primi che possono essere manipolati
ma valutare alcuna azienda per quanti
giovani assunto perché sicuramente se
un'azienda assume tanti giovani è
un'azienda che va bene che i conti in
ordine ma soprattutto avrà conti ancora
più in ordine perché da te o giovane
motivazione e possibilità di farsi
valere e farà un lavoro che neppure lo
immaginate in questo modo chiaramente
potremmo avere parecchi benefici del
primo beneficio è probabilmente quello
più ovvio che recuperare un senso di
fiducia di ottimismo migliorare una pace
sociale e togliersi magari quel senso di
angoscia che io vedo tante volte quando
faccio dei colloqui dei ragazzi giovani
alle prime armi
ovviamente avremmo anche dei risultati
economici
ok perché le aziende che assumono
giovani è detto che continua andare
meglio ma soprattutto creeremo nuovi
consumatori che quindi potrebbero essere
da volano alla nostra economia
avremo anche la possibilità
di tenere i nostri migliori cervelli in
italia abbiamo visto oggi anche delle
menti brillanti che sono dovute andare
all'estero e quindi favorire un humus
per l'innovazione per la nascita di
nuove aziende e quindi un volano
positivo in core mio però io credo che
il risultato più bello che potremo
ottenere se faremo un piano di questo
tipo coraggioso e con fiducia e che
avremo tanti bei bambini in più e quelle
che vedete sono le mie due meraviglie
grazie